Okay,
so we're going to wrap up.
Freud today,
so occupies a strange position in the
history of psychology because Freud
wasn't a psychologist.
He was a medical doctor and many of the
people whose theories were discussing
that work clinicians were mds,
not psychologists well,
and of course when Freud was around,
at least when he was trading psychology,
hadn't yet become an independent
science.
Now the same was true of Yom,
and part of the consequence of that was
that when the new science of psychology
developed into what you're studying
today,
the psychoanalysts and the medical
community basically stayed outside of
that and there's never really been a
meeting of the minds between
experimental psychologists and
psychoanalysts.
Although by the 19 eighties,
the cognitive psychologists were
promoting their discovery of the
cognitive unconscious,
which always felt to me a little bit
ungrateful given that Freud had actually
laid the groundwork for the theory of
the unconscious or an elaborated that in
quite great detail.
You know,
almost 100 years before there's some
resistance in this.
And that's what a psychoanalyst would
say.
There is some resistance among the
experimental psychology community to
Credit Freud with any of his real
discoveries and I think that's very
unfortunate,
partly because he did make the
discoveries and be the psychoanalysts
still understand more about the nature
of the unconscious than modern
experimental psychologists because
modern experimental psychologists insist
on viewing the brain as that cognitive
processes.
Something like a computer and that isn't
what it is.
It's a living system composed of other
living subsystems and that means that as
we've discussed already,
that the human psyche and its
subordinate components are better
conceived of as personalities and
subpersonalities than in any other
manner.
Then in systems or an or an information
or that information processing machines
and it's.
It's,
it's I think perhaps the most
fundamental accomplishment of
psychoanalysis following me actually to
view the human mind,
the human psyche as a place of
relatively integrated subpersonalities
being when even when modern people talk
about themselves,
they talk about the eye,
which would be roughly the ego in
Freudian terms.
They tend to think of themselves as a
unitary phenomenon.
But the problem with that notion is that
people continually do things that they
find themselves doing things that in
principle they don't want to do or
things that they're ashamed of or lying
when they don't want a liar,
generally misbehaving,
and so also of course everybody's
observations that you can try to tell
yourself what to do,
but that doesn't work very well.
So you know you've experienced this
undoubtedly in your own life.
Many,
many times when you're sitting down and
you're trying to study for something,
particularly if you're not very
interested in it,
they had all sorts of alternative
possibilities will make themselves
manifest in your,
in the theater of your,
of your imagination,
and in a sense what's happening in in
those situations is that parts of you
that that are organized,
organized around other goals or from the
Friday perspective,
say driven by other desires,
are trying to hijack control of your
motor output and that frequently happens
so that you find yourself,
for example,
procrastinating or rationalizing or
displacing.
Those are all Freudian concepts at
displacement would be,
instead of doing the work you're
supposed to do,
you go off and do some other work.
No,
it's not a bad way of procrastinating,
but it's not great because you're not
focusing on what you should be focusing
on and so in some sense you're at war
with yourself and the major player in
the war,
at least in principle,
is the ego not be equivalent to Freud's
conscious mind.
At least in the initial phases of his
theory.
It's somewhat complicated to talk about
Freud because of course it's theory
developed across time and then in the
beginning he basically broke the mind up
into the conscious mind and the
unconscious mind and you can think of
the conscious mind.
Well that's you.
Essentially that's the you that you can
refer to during day to day experience
and then the unconscious mind is a
storehouse of two broad classes of
phenomena and one would be drives that
are grounded in instinct that are either
at odds with your current goal or
memories often traumatic that you
haven't been able to integrate into your
conscious framework.
And so those pesky things take on their
own life.
You know,
if you,
if you take an animal and you take out
increasingly large segments of its
cortex,
say the animal still organizes itself
into that animal,
like it starts to lose function,
especially if you go deep into the brain
and you can kill an animal if you go
deep into the brain.
But if you stay on the cortical surface,
you can take an awful lot of brain
tissue out without interfering with a
lot of the animal's ability to sustain
itself.
And what that shows is that the brain is
organized in such a way.
So that isolated components of it will
take on a function of the entire
personality and that demonstration in
some sense that these sub elements of
the psyche or or perhaps subsystems,
subsystems of the brain can organize
themselves into functional living units.
And it stands to reason.
I mean if you lose an arm,
you don't start functioning.
You just reorganize your personality
minus the arm.
And if you,
you.
If,
if you have only managed to integrate a
certain subset of the potential psychic
manifestations of your mind,
then that subset is going to formulate
the main personality,
but all the other things that you're
ignoring,
their can't integrate.
They're going to have a life of their
own.
They don't just disappear,
and so Freud offers the unsettling idea
that you're by no means master in your
own house,
and one of the ways you can determine
that is by watching yourself do things
that you don't want to do,
and those are things,
for example,
that you'd have a hard time facing up to
because of course,
most of the things that you don't want
to do are things that you might be
ashamed of or anxious about.
And then of course there's the defeat
that you suffer when you.
When your ego is hypothetically in
control of this circumstance and you
find your behavior or your thoughts
directed in some direction under the
control of something that you think that
you've mastered.
You can really see this in conditions
like anorexia.
So especially if it's accompanied by
Bulemia,
which it often is.
So anorexia is a.
An eating disorder that causes people,
I think essentially become extremely
disgusted with their own physiology,
with their own physical being and it
works their perceptions terribly.
So I had a,
uh,
an anorexic client at one point and she
was a rather small woman of maybe five
to or something like that.
Quite thin.
Obviously she had anorexia and I asked
her when she was in my office if her
thigh was bigger or smaller than mine.
And she said,
well it was about the same size.
So I took a piece of paper and I'm
saddle on it and I drew the outline of
my thigh on it.
And then I had her sit on the same piece
of paper and she drew the outline of her
thigh.
And of course there was probably that
much space on both sides.
Between the two outlines,
which probably looked at that for 15
minutes,
you know,
she,
she could not believe that that could
possibly be the case.
And I think what happens in our
anorexics is that they stopped being
able to look up their whole bodies.
So when you,
when you look at yourself in the mirror,
you kind of have to look in a gestalt
manner.
You have to get a picture of the whole.
Alternatively you can focus on small
parts,
but the more you focus on parts,
the more difficult it is to see the
parts in relationship to the whole and
anorexics get unbelievably focused on
small elements and they confuse
themselves.
So for example,
if they're looking at their arms and
there's some flesh on it,
they they are unable to make a
distinction between the flesh and fat
and they want no fat.
They want to go right down to the bone
and they can't because they're concerned
about that tiny little part or maybe
this tiny little park or wherever they
happen to be focused there.
They get completely unable to perceive
their own bodies and it's quite striking
how,
how far that can go.
And then the end of it is,
well,
the person will start themselves for a
long period of time and of course we'll
think about this and modern
physiological terms.
Feeding behavior is regulated by the
hypothalamus.
And that's a.
that's an ancient brain area that
controls fundamental motivational
systems and it's right above the spinal
cord and it's a very,
very,
very powerful center of Control and the
brain.
It's functional enough.
I think I told you this before,
that if you take a cat and you take off
it's entire cortex and even most of its
emotional systems,
if you leave it just with the
hypothalamus and the spinal cord,
which basically means it has almost no
brain.
It can organize its behavior almost
perfectly as long as you keep it in a
simple environment.
So anyways,
the anorexic attempts to starve,
but so that's a conscious goal you might
say or or that might be an ego related
goal or you could even think about it as
a goal that's motivated by other
unconscious forces because maybe she
doesn't know exactly why she wants to
start,
but in any case,
what generally happens is she'll run
into an emotionally upsetting situation.
Now,
emotional upset,
say it.
It makes you anxious or it puts you in
emotional pain.
That activates higher brain centers.
Then the hypothalamus,
but they're still pretty low.
They're still pretty primordial and one
of the things that kind of emotional
upset does,
let's call it stress,
is shut off your longterm planning and
the reason for that is,
is that if you're stressed in the in
the,
in,
in the immediate,
now your body and brain presume that you
should devote divert resources from the
hypothetical future to solving the
problem that's right in front of you and
that's often a more behaviorally
oriented a solution like freezing or
withdrawing or something like that.
So it shuts off your prefrontal cortex.
And as soon as that happens,
then the hypothalamus,
which is,
as I said,
a very powerful system just reaches up
in some sense and dominates the person.
I mean it's been there for God only
knows how long,
you know,
tens of millions of years and it's job
is to stop you from starving to death.
And you know,
you can imagine that over the course of
evolutionary history,
anybody who had a relatively weak
feeding instinct died and so they
weren't our ancestors.
And so what happens to the Balsamic is
something will upset them and then
they'll get an uncontrollable desire.
For often something that's high calorie
and sweet and full of fat,
logically enough because they're
starving and then they'll eat like a
whole quart of ice cream and two loaves
of bread and you know,
they described the state that they're in
while they're doing that as dissociated,
you know,
it doesn't feel like them.
Well,
you can imagine why in some sense,
I mean partly is the whole realm of
eating behavior and it eating is as some
personality.
It's not just a behavior.
It's not a drive.
Like when you think about when you're
hungry,
it's not like your brain is moving.
You literally step by determined step.
It's that you start fantasizing about
food and you start thinking about what
you may be wanted.
Then you start to make plans about where
you're going to go or how you're going
to cook and what social.
You know,
what social surround there's going to be
in a whole bunch of things and that's,
that's the hungry you well in an,
in an anorexic or Bulimic,
the hungry part of the person is so
dissociated from the part,
the ego apart,
but they're basically in a war.
But one of the problems with being in a
war with your hypothalamus is that it
almost always wins and it's a good thing
because otherwise you die,
you know,
and lots of anorexics do manage to
starve themselves to death.
And so that's a good example of just
exactly how dissociable the mind can be
in the mind is,
is also the brain is dissociable in the
strangest possible ways.
So here's an example.
Um,
I don't remember the name of this
syndrome.
It might pop into my mind,
but so you can have a particular kind of
stroke.
And here's the effect of the stroke.
You develop the fixed delusion that a
person who's very close to you capgras
syndrome,
a person who's very close to you has
been,
has died or being kidnapped or somehow
disappeared and has been replaced by
their exact double.
And so and so.
It's obviously something,
it manifests itself as something akin to
psychosis.
And what happens is that the stroke
damages the relationship between the
generally,
the visual systems that identify faces
and the emotional systems that tag the
identified face with familiar emotions.
So basically what happens is,
let's say it happens to you and it's
your mother,
you look at your mother,
but it isn't your mother,
you know,
your mother comes with a whole complex
of memories and you know she's sat in a,
in a very broad context of memory and
emotion and then you look at this person
and it looks like your mother,
but none of that is happening.
And so then you develop this idea as
well.
If it's not my mother,
it looks exactly like my mother.
Well then what could possibly be going
on?
And the answer is,
well obviously she's being taken away
and replaced by her exact duplicate.
People get into real trouble with this
sort of delusion as you might imagine
because they get obsessed with trying to
solve the problem.
Like what did you do with my mother?
And you can understand why,
but here's the,
here's a weirder thing even which is
that it's,
it's modality specific so that if they
listen to their mother on the phone,
that's their mother.
So.
So you see exactly how dissociable the
brain is.
The mind is even down to small sub
functions,
so there are people with strokes who can
sing but who can't talk,
and there are people who lose nouns and
there are people who lose only versed
and there are people who can identify
things but they can't name them.
So the idea that the brain is a
dissociable entity is obviously correct.
And here's another example of it,
while you dissociate all the time.
Now,
if you look at the way the brain is
structured,
so there's a strip right about here
called the motor strip,
and if you are doing brain surgery and
you touch someone with an electrode on
that strip,
they'll move the corresponding part of
the body.
And the hands are very,
very overrepresented.
And so is the face and the lips and the
tongue for obvious reasons.
We fiddle around with the world a lot.
We move our arms and our hands a lot,
the feeder overrepresented too.
And then we communicate about that with
our face and our tongues.
So there's huge representation there.
Um,
so and if you touch that,
you'll get an emotion,
or at least the person will will
describe a strong impulse to move well
out of that grew the prefrontal cortex
and the best way to think of people
think about that as the substrate of
abstract thought.
It's not really a good way of thinking
about it because you're not really out
to think you're out to act and the
reason you think is so that you can try
out some actions in a little world of
fantasy before you implement them in
your behavior.
Right?
So to think thing things through means
to conjure up an abstracted world and
then to conjure up a representation of
yourself acting in that world to
calculate the consequences and then to
decide whether you're going to implement
it.
Well,
that's another form of dissociate
ability because you can think without
acting,
now you know,
it certainly that part of you that's
able to conjure up the alternative
worlds that human beings seem to
particularly identify with.
You know that part that's thinking,
at least modern people really think of
the part that's thinking as them or the
part that's capable of abstract ideas,
and if it wasn't dissociable,
you'd just act out everything you
thought,
well that wouldn't work very well,
so the brain is actually designed in
many ways,
so to speak,
to be dissociable now.
So if you understand that and then you
understand the two,
the two ela,
the two sets of phenomena that are
likely to be dissociated,
then you kind of got the essence of
Freudian theory and the things that are
likely to be dissociated are one
memories that were traumatic,
and I'll talk about that in a minute.
And two,
impulses,
they're not impulses,
they're not even drives,
which was the freud way of thinking
about it.
They're subpersonalities troublesome
subpersonalities,
and you can imagine that those would be
linked to complex,
positive and negative emotions.
One might be resentment,
guilt,
shame,
anger,
anxiety,
jealousy,
rage,
lust.
All of those emotions are,
are difficult to integrate into a
personality property,
partly because in their pure
manifestation,
they're not there.
They disrupt the social order,
you know,
so like,
think about how well regulated all of
you are sitting here,
you know,
and you think,
well,
you're 6 million years since you
dissociated or since you've diverged
from chimpanzees,
if we took a bunch of chimpanzees that
knew each other as well as you know each
other,
this place would be an absolute brutal
massacre.
So you know,
for,
for whatever reason,
you can control your primordial
instincts.
That's one way of looking at it.
That's how Freud would look at it.
You've learned to control them.
And Freud's theory,
and this is where it differs from the
theories that we talked about earlier,
say with regards to piaget,
Freud's theory is really more about
control.
He thought of all of these potential
subsystems and memories conflicting with
each other like a war,
like a hog Z in war.
So hobbes was the philosopher who said
that life is nasty,
brutal,
and short.
And that in the state of nature,
everyone is at war with everyone else.
And so you need a,
um,
a Leviathan,
a top down control system,
a Leviathan who will punish any deviance
from the social contract.
Well,
that's the Freudian Super Ego.
Now,
Freud thought of the unconscious and the
conscious mind to begin with,
but later he dissociated that up into in
ego and superego.
And then he thought that each of those
had their unconscious elements.
So you know,
so you,
if you're under the grip of an ID
related subpersonality,
let's say you could be conscious of
that,
but there's the possibility for all
sorts of other interrelated
subpersonalities to emerge.
So those would be in your unconscious
and it's also possible and highly likely
in fact,
that the way that you're perceiving the
world and the way you're acting in it,
and even what you state as your goals
are influenced in ways that you don't
understand by the action of these
unconscious system.
So for example,
you know,
maybe some of you are headed for medical
school.
And if I asked you why,
you will give me six humanitarian
reasons.
But the actual reason is is because you
know your grandmother would be
disappointed if you weren't and she
might not even be alive anymore,
you know,
she may have,
your mother may have imitated your
grandmother so that that ideal is firmly
embodied in her and that set up the
unspoken expectations about your
behavior ever since you were a tiny
child.
So now it's an interesting sub element
of,
of psychodynamic theory too,
and it's really something to watch for
in your personal relationships.
It's very,
very frequently if you watch carefully
that you can see someone,
especially someone you love because you
have to know them well being taken over
in some sense by the spirit of one of
their ancestors.
And I don't mean this in a metaphysical
way.
I mean that the,
the,
the thought,
the personality of the grandmother or
the personality of the mother has a,
has a structure that's well known to
the,
to the individual in question and that
individual spent a lot of time imitating
them in all sorts of ways and those
imitated structures.
Can it be passed down generation to
generation?
I mean,
in fact,
that's partly what constitutes your
culture,
right?
It's the imitated personality of all of
your ancestors that constitutes your
culture and those things can possess
you.
Ideologies possess you and exact not
exactly the same way,
but in a very similar way.
So,
okay,
so you've got the end and you've got the
ego and the Superego,
and as in the hot seat and worldview,
there's real tension between them so
that the end is always trying to get
it's based gratifications,
it's based desires,
gratifying.
Now in the infrared and times that was
mostly problematic in relationship to
sex and the reasons for that are quite
clear.
There was no valid birth control.
There was very little employment option
for women.
So there sexual behavior had to be very,
very,
very tightly regulated or they'd fall
outside of the social structure into
prostitution or something like that.
And then there was the threat of various
venereal diseases,
most particularly syphilis,
which is as awful,
uh,
diseases you can imagine if it could
imitate or mimic all sorts of other
diseases.
And it's transmissible from mother to
child.
So it's a nasty one.
So sick,
it was very difficult for the victorians
to integrate sexuality because,
well,
exactly how did you do that?
They're the one pathway to potential
integration.
Something the Super Ego say would
approve of was American pathway,
but you know,
people back then back in the 19 sixties,
people were getting married around 19 or
20,
but that's actually a historical
anomaly.
I mean typically speaking in the
Victorian age,
a man usually couldn't afford to get
married until he was in his mid to late
twenties.
He just didn't have the resources,
so women were married usually younger
than that,
but so there was a long period of time
for,
for men particularly,
but also for women where the sexual
drive from a Freudian perspective was in
full,
was fully flourishing,
fully manifesting itself,
but there was no socially approved mode
of expression and so under those
conditions there's a war between the ID
and the superego in a sense,
and Portland ego was crushed in the
middle.
Now you could certainly see that when we
were watching the movie,
the crumb brothers movie,
because they are basically in the same
situation,
right?
There was no socially approved way that
they could manifest any sexual or any
aggressive behavior and what happened as
a consequence was that the both of those
fundamental subpersonalities,
let's call them,
become incredibly pathologized as
particularly characterized by resentment
and the desire for revenge.
Because remember,
these systems think,
you know,
if someone's excrutiatingly sexually
frustrated,
let's say,
and let's think about it in the broader
scheme of things because sexuality isn't
really.
It's not a narrow unit.
Dimensional drive it,
you know it's associated with
playfulness and it's associated with the
desire for social contact and the desire
for communication and the desire for
touching like it's a complicated multi
branching phenomenon.
Well in in the case of the people who
were watching in the movie,
none of that was either integrate it
into their personalities,
let's say,
or permitted by society and so it it.
It was bent and warped and and
frustrated and then generated all sorts
of ideas about resentment and revenge
around it.
So you can develop an incredibly,
an incredibly pathological
subpersonality.
In the one cartoon,
if you remember when it was the one that
was most disturbing,
where Mr Natural brought Robert that
headless woman,
so he wanted pure gratification without
responsibility,
so it's a really driven phenomena and so
he had intercourse with her and
immediately asked her that was
unbelievably guilty.
You know when you can see,
so you think about what that must mean.
It's like someone is under the grip of
one subpersonalities.
It shaping all of their thoughts and
their memories and their emotions and
all of a sudden that becomes gratified
so it's satiated.
It disappears in Bang up comes the other
one and it's you know,
wealth.
In this particular example,
it was guilt and shame and anxiety,
terror even and self loathing.
All of those things.
And if you read about the experiences of
people who commit particularly atrocious
crimes,
it's very,
very common for them to experience
exactly that.
They are driven by sexual slash
aggressive impulses because those are
generally the ones that culminated in
the particularly atrocious,
you know,
individual crimes and they'll commit
them and then the instantly flipped back
into their normative personality.
Except they're absolutely terrified by
what they did and you know it's more
than one person is inhabiting the same
psych and it's very.
Now they're tied together by memory.
Generally speaking.
Although Freud would say you can also
dissociate memory and so Freud talked,
talked about memories being repressed
and that's caused an awful lot of
trouble because,
well,
for a whole variety of reasons because
because memory is not,
memory is not the object of recording.
It's not the objective unbiased
recording of actually occurring events.
First of all,
because you can't actually objective
where you record certain kinds of nets.
Like we talked about this before.
You can't really objective where you
record a discussion between a man and a
woman who'd been married for 20 years
about anything important because for
them,
each word and each phrase and each
sentence and each facial expression has
to be interpreted within the context of
the entire relationship.
In order for the meaning of the
utterances to be extracted and there's
just no way you can record that in the
video.
You.
You'd have to have videoed the entire
relationship and so you're not going to
do that.
And so memory is a very,
very peculiar thing and the idea that
you could have an objective restaurant
is not a very sophisticated idea
anyways.
Freud's idea in some sense he had a
somewhat,
I hate to say it was an inner
sufficiently sophisticated notion of
what memory was.
Now I hate to say that because Freud was
a very sophisticated person,
but he did in some sense believe in the
existence of an objective interpersonal
world.
And so he thought if something terrible
happened to you when you were a child,
that you had a record of the memory.
It was there as the memory as the event
and then you needed something that would
like a sensor that would repress that
and then you needed a place for it to be
repressed into which would be the
unconscious.
But if you.
But if you take a part,
a traumatic memory,
generally speaking with someone,
I heard that he also.
He also thought that that repressed
memory might be represented in a,
in a symptom,
a symbolic symptom.
So I think,
I think that the repression theory
suffers from the inadequacy of its
representation of memory because he,
here's a different way of thinking about
it.
It's more in keeping with the layer
model,
the hierarchical layer model that we've
been entertaining as we progress.
So imagine that your,
um,
molested by your uncle because it's
usually a family member when you're for
sexually molested.
Okay?
The first thing you have to ask yourself
is just exactly what kind of memory do
you have.
Imagine you're completely sexually
naive,
which basically means you know nothing
about the sexual act and,
and it's,
and it's implications or the mechanics.
But this happens to you.
So the first question is how do you
represent that?
And that sir,
is because to rip,
to remember something,
you have to represent it.
That's,
that's the thing is you don't just have
a memory of that event.
It's always interpretation because
there's so many things going on.
Well,
so maybe you,
maybe your representation is pain and
confusion,
something like that.
And then there'd be another layer over
that which would be the necessity for
secrecy because of course the person who
does the molesting is going to tell you,
well,
one of two things,
three,
maybe it's good for you,
you asked for it,
don't tell anyone or or they'll think
you're a bad person.
This will be our little secret.
Something like that.
So then there's that whole overlay of
secrecy and inadmissibility and what are
you supposed to do about that?
When you're for how are you supposed to
understand that something has just
transpired,
that you're not allowed to share with
anyone.
You don't have a model of the world
that's sophisticated enough to account
for all that.
And so then
perhaps from then on,
what you do is avoid thinking about it.
Now.
That's not the same as repression.
Avoiding thinking about something is not
the same as repression because it
doesn't require an active repressor in
order to do it.
And then maybe you know,
years later you start to recall what
happened,
but what you recall is an unclear mess
and the read and maybe most of it
because you might say,
well,
how are things represented as memories
when you can't develop a sophisticated
representation and what seems to happen?
And this is in a sense,
the reason reversive Freudian theory is
that
the,
the
event is represented in the body.
And so you can think about the
representation of advantage as a
multilayered neurological phenomenon.
And so if you encounter something that's
unexpected or frightening,
the first thing that happens is very,
very ancient reflex of systems act
first.
And those things are fast.
And so that's the sort of thing that,
for example,
might protect you against the snake
bite.
If a snake jumped out at you,
we're going to jump backwards.
And believe me,
you do that before you even see the
snake because it takes you a quarter to
second to produce complex visual
representation of the snake.
And if you wait around for recorder for
a second,
then you're dead.
And so what's happened is that your
nervous system has conserved basic
reflexes that are only a few synapses
long,
so maybe those work between your retina
and your spinal cord,
your retina,
and maybe a very primordial emotional
system like the Amygdala is wired up to
detect things like snakes and it just
sends a message down to your spinal cord
or or slightly more sophisticated motor
control systems that says,
jump backwards now and then maybe you
think about it isn't even till after
that that your heart rate goes up and
your blood pressure goes up and you
start to breathe heavily and then
there's a wave of fear and revulsion,
which is perhaps there to teach you not
to do such a stupid thing again.
You know,
we don't exactly know why you would
experience negative emotion,
you know,
or what function the negative emotion
has,
except that we do know that a pattern of
neurological behavior that's followed by
a punishment or a threat is likely less
likely to be reimplemented in the
future.
Okay.
So the reaction to the anomalous thing
is broadly and then maybe it's emotion
and then maybe it's image,
like imagination,
you know,
what just happened and then maybe it's
articulated speech,
but lots of things don't get past image
to articulating speech and some things I
think don't even get past body.
Sorry about that.
So I don't think that these traumatic
memories are so much repressed as Freud
had it,
as never brought forward for
development.
So,
um,
let me,
I'll tell you a story about how this
might work.
Okay.
So one time I had this client,
she was about 27.
I only saw her once,
this is when I was training to be a
psychotherapist and she came into me and
she said that she had been plagued by
these thoughts of being sexually abused
when she was a child.
And I said,
well,
who was doing this to you?
And she said,
well,
it was my brother.
And I said,
she said he was a lot older than me.
And so I formulated this medical model
of her being,
you know,
somewhere between 10 and 13 and her
brother being somewhere between say 15
and 20,
because the way she described it was,
you know,
that she was overpowered by a larger,
a physically larger male.
So we talked for awhile and then she
finally told me,
I said,
well,
how old were you when this happened?
And she said,
well,
I was for okay.
And now.
And then I said,
well,
okay,
how old was your brother?
And she said,
well,
he was six.
And so I said,
well look,
you know,
here's one way of looking at it,
like you're looking at it from the
perspective of the four year old.
It's a regression in some sense.
That's still how old you are as far as
experiencing the memory.
Here's an alternative hypothesis.
Your brother wasn't a predator.
You were both terribly supervise
children.
Well,
you know,
that made the lights go on in your inner
mind because she'd never thought about
it that way.
Like she'd never taken that
representation,
which would be her emotional experience
as a four year old related to a six year
old.
Six year old is a lot bigger and more
powerful than four-year-olds.
Right?
It's is,
it's,
you know,
50 percent owner.
So it's a big deal when you're four.
But if the,
if the issue for the memory is its
relevance to current conceptualization
and behavior,
it was much better for her to update the
memory in a sense and think,
well yeah,
like a six year olds this and like the
Oreos this high and like what the hell
were my parents doing anyways?
And that's an entirely different story
than,
than the one that she had come up with
kid come in with,
you know.
And that seemed to be a great relief to
her.
And that's partly because you know,
if you're bothered by a traumatic
memory,
it keeps resurfacing on which it will.
And it's actually one of the ways of
identifying a traumatic memory is that
the thing won't leave you alone.
It keeps coming up and dreams.
And when your mind is wandering,
it'll keep coming up.
When your mind is wandering and maybe
it'll come up when you're going to sleep
at night and like it invades your mind.
There's a reason for that and the reason
is is that the underlying emotional
systems that are associated with
anxiety,
so those are mostly hippocampus and then
maybe a lot of dual duo in some sense
that are mediating those there an alarm
system and the alarm is something that's
potentially dangerous has happened.
You need to figure out what it means so
that you can stop that from happening in
the future.
Okay,
so you need a plan.
You need and get applied and you do have
to do a causal analysis of the
relationship between your behavior and
the traumatic outcome.
That would be the first thing and then
you have to come up with a way that that
won't happen again.
And of course for my client,
that happened pretty much right away
because now she was a 27 year old woman
in the probability that she was going to
be subject in any serious way to a
situation.
The same as the one she was remembering
was zero.
But,
and I've seen this in other clients too,
is when they're,
when they're,
when,
okay.
I had another client who,
who,
uh,
when she was,
I think I told you about her briefly
when she was young,
four years old,
she jumped in a shopping cart and went
down a hill,
like a paved hail in the shopping cart
and spilled out at the bottom and hurt
herself and they took her to the
hospital and,
you know,
so then she's all primed for being
threatened and men.
So that's kind of means you're open to
rewire reading some sense in this.
So then when she's in the hospital,
they don't let her parents come and see
her for a couple of weeks,
you know,
so the trauma,
the pain and the anxiety and the threat
than the ambulance ride and all those
things,
which sort of puts her in a state like
this,
which might be a,
like a,
a state that's particular to conducive
to learning.
If something traumatic is happening,
you should be learning about that.
What the world's like around that right
now.
And uh,
she developed at a permanent trauma
related paranoia about institutions
which turned by the time I met her,
had turned into a whole philosophy of
institutional oppression,
but it's core was that Tara,
and rightly so,
it's core was that combination of
physiological trauma and psychological
trauma and you know,
miss handling of the situation by people
in authority.
So,
so you can see under those circumstances
how a traumatic memory can become the
core of a whole large subpersonality.
Now it has to be taken apart very
carefully,
especially if that subpersonality isn't
the kind that can be easily integrated
into the world.
So for example,
if you're paranoid about all
institutions,
you're in real trouble because in a
modern world you're faced with the
necessity of dealing with institutions
all the time.
And if you're more distrustful and
paranoid about them,
then you couldn't be.
If you were sophisticated,
all of it's going to happen is they're
going to continually mistreat you,
right?
Because I mean,
if a dog comes up to you and it's,
it's looking suspiciously and barking
and growling,
you're not going to pet it.
You know,
the way you interact with the system is
depends the,
the reaction of a system to you is
dependent to a large degree on how you
approach the system.
So anyways,
the dissociate ability ideas,
they're really good one.
I mean
if you want to get to know yourself
better,
and this is sort of a combination of
Friday and in union ideas,
one of the things to do is to.
So imagine that you have some sort of
goal in mind.
The first question is you that you might
ask yourself is why do you have that
goal?
What are the influences on you that have
set that goal up?
Because it easily could be conscious or
partially conscious or poorly explained
or implicit any of those things.
So you want to know that why are you
doing what you're doing?
And the second thing is if you find
yourself avoiding things on the way to
that goal,
the next question is why are you
avoiding them?
And you know,
that'll mean delving into parts of
yourself that are quite hidden and quite
uncomfortable.
So for example,
if you discover that the reason you're
pursuing a particular goal is because
it's what your parents want you to do,
one question that immediately arises,
rises is,
yeah,
but is that what you want to do?
And you know that that's a very
complicated question because you'd have
to dissociate the part of you that's the
you that doesn't want to do it from the
part of you that's the you that does
want to do it,
and then you have to figure out why in
the world you'd be avoiding.
So you know it might be that you're an
unbelievably angry that you've been
tilted towards this particular goal for
reasons that have nothing to do with
your choice and so that every time you
have the opportunity to study or,
or accomplish something that would move
you farther to that goal,
you're either not motivated.
So you can't pay attention.
You can't study,
you can't learn and you procrastinate
all the time or you actually do
seriously counterproductive thing.
So people,
for example,
people can be.
I just had someone write me here a while
ago because he was watching the youtube
lectures and he said that he had dreams
for six weeks,
that he drove his car off a cliff and
crashed it,
and then at the end of the series he
drove his car off the cliff and crashed
it and he asked me what that meant,
and I said,
well,
the dream is telling you that you're
being far too careless with your life.
Like maybe that's what driving a cliff
off a car off a cliff repeatedly needs.
It's like you know,
that's a good descent unconscious
descent into the underworld.
Well,
and he was being warned.
The psychological reality was such that
the warning was extremely serious and so
was the danger.
So then you might say,
well,
why would he drive himself off a cliff?
Well,
you know,
that's a suicidal gesture.
And then you might ask,
well,
why would somebody be suicidal?
And that could be,
well,
they're out for revenge against their
parents or they're out for revenge
against the whole world or the route for
revenge against themselves.
Or they just want to make their painful
consciousness go away,
or they're living a messy and pointless
and painful life and and they want to
punish themselves for it and you know
it's very,
very complicated and tangled down there
at the bottom of things and people don't
really like to look into it and I
suppose to some degree that's the shadow
element because what you find there is
seldom what you want in one of the prime
dictums of union psychotherapy and most
psychotherapies are predicated on the
idea that you should find out what
you're avoiding and then you should
figure out how to voluntarily face it.
Now you might add to that you should
find out what you're doing and why and
see if that's actually what you want to
be doing and if those reasons are
reasons you like that might,
you know,
in some sense some up therapy in a
couple of phrases,
but
in order to manage that,
then you have to look at all the things
you've been avoiding.
Well,
what do you avoid?
it isn't rainbows and cookies,
right?
The things that you avoid are the things
that no one wants to look at,
and so your primary dictum for his
psychotherapeutic practice was a Latin
phrase which is in sterk wiliness
infinite tour,
which I'm probably pronouncing wrong,
which means either in filth it will be
found or where are you want most is to
be found where you least want to look.
You know when those are.
That's what that.
That's a horrible philosophy,
but you can see that it's almost self.
It's almost self fulfilling because of
course the things you're going to avoid.
Are there things that you don't want to
face?
Obviously now the shadow element of the
psyche in some sense when you were
watching the movie for example,
you saw these drives mostly sexual and
aggressive that were manifesting
themselves in all sorts of ways and so
that would be maybe the repressed or
unincorporated elements of the Ed,
but then there was a side of.
There was another more complex side of
that where the,
the,
the people were reacting to that,
you know,
because they felt downtrodden and
oppressed and and antisocial and
critical of social structure.
And all of that,
because they were unable to manifest
themselves properly in the world and
that produced fantasies of extreme
destruction,
exceptional destruction for them.
They were mostly sexually related,
but for other people that can manifest
itself in incredibly violent fantasies
about the destruction of society as
such.
So
if you can invite all the parts of you
out to play,
the parts that get left behind are not
very happy about it and they don't just
sit around having a tea party,
you know,
they turn into,
they turn it into,
especially as you mature,
they turn into these worked monsters and
their,
their mode of action in the world is
anything but positive.
And the Freudian world and the world of
the psychoanalytic unconscious is quite
a terrifying place because it makes you
second guess everything.
It's like it's not a paranoia out.
Okay.
You never.
It's very,
very difficult.
Once you're trained psychoanalytically
to ever assume that someone's benevolent
motivations are only what they claim
they are,
you're always looking for the other
missing piece.
And,
and I think it's extremely useful
because,
you know,
you run into people particularity
ideologues who will claim that they're
acting on the world's behalf.
It's like,
yeah,
who made us sane and why should I
believe that all the good is on your
side.
Like,
what is it that you're not talking
about?
What it is that,
what is it that you're not revealing?
I got something from Greenpeace once,
for example,
that was asking for donations and the
brochure was just photographs of all the
people who were on the board.
I thought,
why do I want to see photographs of all
the people who are on the board of
Greenpeace,
or the other question is why do they
want to show them?
Well,
you don't have to faint very hard to
figure that out.
You know,
it's a status maneuver,
what you'd expected to mail out like
that as you know,
here's six things that we've done in the
last year that improve the planet and
you know,
here's what we spent in relationship to
administrative costs and here's why it
was a good idea or not,
here's our leaders.
Now there's something wrong there.
And I mean that's,
I picked Greenpeace because it just
happened to pop in money,
but it's the case for all sorts of of
organizations.
So all right,
so
freud by 1900 had identified a lot of
different functions of the unconscious
and so here's four of them.
One was the unconscious,
how to conservative function,
which meant that it stored memories
often unaccessible to voluntary recall.
Now we don't really know how memories
are stored in the brain,
but here's,
here's a guess.
So when you have an experience,
imagine that that produces a pattern of
neural activity.
It's not just neuro,
but a pattern of activity in your brain
and in your body,
at least part of how you remember it is
to reactivate that pattern,
but it's not that simple obviously
because otherwise you docked out all
your memories precisely and we don't
know exactly how that initial
pattern of experienced gets edited down
to the thing you remember.
But we do know that it,
it gets edited down in some ways as a
consequence of its relevance to your
current goal structure.
How that happens,
it seems computationally impossible.
We really don't understand how it
happens at all.
We don't understand how you can compute
what's relevant and what isn't.
It seems that the world is too complex
for that to even be possible.
So Conservative dissoluted the
unconscious contains habits once
voluntary,
now automatized and dissociated elements
of the personality which may lead a
parasitic existence.
That's so I talked to a little bit about
traumatic memories and how they might
form the node of the development of a
subpersonality,
but there's something else that's worth
understanding too.
So let's say you.
You start practicing a new minor mode of
being a new attitude or a new
personality attribute or new habit.
Let's say it can be a fairly small
thing.
When you first start practicing it,
you're not very good at it.
For those of you who are musicians,
you know when you first start to play a
piece,
you're very inefficient at it and then
the more you practice it,
the more efficient you get it.
It's quite weird.
I'm not a very good pianist,
but I learned to play one really
difficult song,
but the terrible thing is is I'll learn
to play it and then at some point I'll
realize that I don't know the notes
anymore and as soon as I realized I
don't know the notes,
I can't use those habit patterns anymore
and then I have to figure out the notes
again.
It's very,
very annoying,
but anyways,
when you first start practicing
something,
it's effortful.
It requires a lot of brain activation.
That's what the scanning studies show,
but as you practice it more and more,
the amount of the brain that you use
starts to shrink.
It generally moves left because the
right hemisphere is more involved in
novelty processing.
It generally moves left and then it
moves back and the area gets smaller and
smaller and smaller until you generate
it up a little machine or it's a little
hard wired.
Some personality that takes care of that
particular operation.
Now that's where thinking about too,
because what that means in some senses
that your brain is full of the things
that you've practiced and that's not
exactly psychological right?
It's psychophysiological,
it's part of your psyche,
but it's also hardwired into your brain.
If you want to overcome one of those
habits,
you have to build a new machine that
shuts it off.
You can't just get rid of it and then
what happens?
If you get stressed?
Often that new machine will get,
I don't know exactly how it happens.
The stress will reduce the functioning,
the new machine and old habit to pop
back up.
Some of you will have noticed this.
How many of you have moved away from
home?
Okay,
so how many of you know this?
When you go to your family of origin,
origin,
that all sorts of personality traits
that you thought you abandoned
immediately come flooding back.
So are you,
you know that,
you know that sensation,
right?
You go back there and it's like bang,
there's a groove and you're right in it
and you know,
maybe you're as mature as a 30 year old
when you're at your own house,
but as soon as you come home it's like
poof,
you're 14 again.
And it's partly because that's the
expectancy situation set up by your
parents,
but it's also partly because you just
don't understand how much of your
behavior is automatic and cued by
ongoing you best.
It's habitual.
And so those you might think of those as
somewhat dissociated elements of the
personality as well.
Creative.
The unconscious serves as the Matrix of
new ideas.
So that's a more union idea and the way
that seems to work,
you might think,
how in the world can you come up with a
new idea?
It doesn't make sense,
right?
I mean,
what are you conjuring something out of?
Nothing.
Well,
you could say,
well they're combinations of old ideas,
but you know,
that's not that helpful because you
can't just take a bunch of old ideas and
shuffled them and come up with some new
spectacular ideas.
It's a lot more complicated than that.
So here's one way to think about
forward,
investigated in some sense,
the surface of the creative unconscious.
And he was more concerned about the.
He don't call Freud's unconscious,
the personal unconscious.
So that might be the unconscious that
you have that's related specifically to
your experiences,
conscious and unconscious,
like it can be deep.
You have a dream once,
for example,
hope I've got this right that Freud and
him were excavating the basement of a
structure and that and then he broke
through and found another huge structure
underneath that and that's just about
exactly right.
And so there's the personal unconscious
and then underneath that,
in theory there's what you called the
collective unconscious and that would be
God only knows what that is,
but in part what it would be is whatever
it is that makes you human from an
evolutionary perspective and we don't
know like you have a specific mode of
being that's a human mode of big.
I think it was Eo Wilson who's a great
entomologist and also the originator of
sociobiology,
which is like a branch of evolutionary
psychology.
He studied dance forever and social
behavior of ants and he's sad if,
if we can talk to and we wouldn't have
anything to say to them.
And what he meant by that is that like
interested in a bunch of things that you
just don't care about at all.
Like they're not jealous.
They don't get jealous,
they don't fall in love,
they don't have sexual feelings or
behaviors.
They're not a cognitive creature.
It's like,
what the hell are you going to talk
through now?
It's about how it's,
how is it going and carrying that grain
of sand.
It's like an aunt as an impact,
doesn't even care about that.
And so it's interesting.
It's really a profound observation
because what it indicates is that you
couldn't even communicate with someone
unless you were 99 percent the same as
they are.
Because to communicate with someone
means you have to share a whole massive,
immense set of presuppositions.
So for example,
if I say I got jealous at a party last
week,
it's like,
you're not going to say,
what do you mean jealous?
That isn't going to be your question.
You're gonna say,
well,
what were their particular circumstances
that elicited that response?
I don't have to explain anger.
I don't have to explain playfulness,
hunger.
Oh,
you know,
all the basic human motivations that you
see displayed,
say in the typical adventure movie or
romantic comedy,
it's like those don't need explanation
because we're the same and it's that
sameness that constitutes the essence of
the collective unconscious.
Now yeomans hypothesis was that you're
not only biologically structured,
you know in terms of your morphology of
your physiology,
but that that extends right up into your
brain structure and even above that,
into the contents.
Either the contents of your psyche or at
least into the way that your psyche
becomes organized across time and you
know,
it seems.
It seems like a hypothesis that's so
bloody obvious that you can't believe
that people would have disputed it for
so long,
but experimental psychologists were very
strongly influenced by behaviorists and
the behaviorist assumed partly through
the illogical reasons and partly for the
sake of scientific simplicity that human
beings were blank slates and that all we
were was what we learned.
Well,
there's a book out now called human
universals.
I'm unfortunately,
I can't remember the name of the author
right now,
but it's a book.
It's a work of sociology slash
anthropology and this person has
collected human commonality,
so what's.
What's the same about people everywhere?
Well,
we pretty much all were close sometimes
for protective purposes,
but if not generally,
at least for ceremonial purposes,
there's pair bonding in societies.
People Fall in love.
The basic emotions are the same.
We use fire.
That's a big deal,
you know,
because no other animal can manage that.
There's.
There's literally dozens and dozens of
universal commonalities across people
and that's part of the substructure of
the collective unconscious.
So anyways,
back to the creative idea.
Well,
partly your creative act is going to be
a consequence of your attempts to
integrate the peculiarities of your own
experience with the peculiarities of
your culture and this and that more
general
phenomenon states of being that you
share with other people.
So because you come into the world and
have your own viewpoint,
you're you have access to information
that no other person has access to and
so to some degree that can be the basis
of your creativity.
Just that information,
but then in order to communicate it,
which is also part of being creative,
right?
Because you can't just be creative,
but no one can understand you.
It's more like you're schizophrenic than
like your creative,
right?
You have loose associations and so
forth,
but you cannot put together a coherent
story,
so then you have to take that unique
information and integrate it with your
cultural knowledge,
your cultural narratives,
and grounded in universal human biology,
and then you can present that as a
creative act.
Now
that's one possible place for the origin
of new ideas,
but here's another.
So
remember we talked about piaget.
Piaget basically said that to begin to
understand something,
you acted out so you represent the world
with your body,
by sitting on a chair.
You represent the chair with your body,
by walking through a doorway.
You represent the doorway with your
body.
By grabbing that glass,
you do the same thing,
so you're matching.
You're imitating the world all the time,
so you're mapping it onto your
physiological structure.
So okay,
so that you get a sense.
That would be.
That's kind of what understanding means.
You know,
because that's a complex term to sort
of,
to understand what does it mean to
understand something means to get a grip
on it and we use those terms for a
reason.
It's to be,
you know,
you're standing firmly in relationship
to it.
You can handle it all of those things.
So that's one.
So that's the beginning.
But then also you're capable of
imitating so you can imitate yourself,
which is what you do when you repeat
experiences that had a positive outcome,
but you can also imitate other people.
Then you think,
okay,
well who are those people imitating?
Well,
the answer to that is it's like we're
led screens and we're constantly
revealing imitations of imitations,
of invitations,
of invitations across our physiological
landscape.
I mean you guys are the sum total of a
very long evolutionary process,
but you're also the sum total of an
incredibly long process of mimicry.
And so what you mimic is your culture,
so you can think of your culture.
It's something with a personality.
It's complex personality and the
personality of your ancestors that
perfectly reasonable way of looking at.
And you imitate that.
No,
that's why we call our our laws of body
of laws,
and you could say that the legal system,
especially with English common law,
is the articulate,
articulated representation of the
imitative customs and rituals of the
entire society.
It's been brought right up into full
articulation,
but it was there to begin with,
so part of where you draw your,
your,
your material for creativity is that you
observed the behaviors and interactions
of all people who've been imitating all
people since the beginning of time and
that's unbelievably informative.
It's way more informative than you could
ever represent.
You know how much information someone
can indicate with just lifting your
eyebrow a quarter of an inch,
right?
That can indicate irony in it can
indicate the relationship of a joke to
another set of jokes that that person
knows that you liked and it's very
complicated.
You can't articulate all that,
but in some sense you know it,
right?
You're a player in that game.
Well,
now and then so then imagine,
okay,
you've got all that embodied to the
degree that you're a sophisticated
player,
then your imagination is representing
you and it's representing the world.
So that's an abstraction,
right?
Because your imagination is not the
world.
It's a representation of the world and
then what you can do.
So that means in the imagination there's
all sorts of information that's about
the imitative behavior and then then you
can talk about the image.
That's sort of what you do when you
interpret a dream.
So what's your dream doing?
Your imagination is watching.
You wandered around in the world.
You know when you have your category
systems and your theories and so forth
and so then the dream puts forth what
that like an image,
an image istick representation of what
that might signify,
and it's in this weird language which is
an image,
an image laden language.
It can be.
It can range from completely incoherent,
just juxtaposed images to unbelievably
complex and sophisticated,
full develop narratives and that's part
of the process by which the information
that's embedded in you and the culture
at a behavioral level moves up to the
imagination and then pops up into
articulated space so you have a dream.
The dream is about you and then you talk
about the dream and what you're doing.
You're trying to translate the images
into articulated representations and
that's also a good way of thinking about
how memory moves from the bottom up and
what's interesting.
You know,
you know,
sometimes you have a realization or a
moment of insight,
you know,
and that there's a feeling that goes
along with that.
It's like a charge and I think it's a
charge that you get from,
from simplifying something,
but also from experiencing the new
possibilities that emerge as a
consequence of that realization.
What seems to happen is that you have
the behavioral realm,
let's say the things you act out and all
the things you imitates very,
very complex.
And then on top of that,
you have the image of that.
Right?
And you're trying to get the image
right,
but it's really hard because this
changes in this floats around so you're
trying to get those lined up and then on
top of that you're trying to get your
articulated representations lined up so
that you can say what you know about who
you are and when all those come together
and you think,
man,
I've got my act together,
but now and then you'll have an insight.
You know,
you'll think,
well,
like this woman who who I told you about
who had be molested.
The insight was while I was a little
kid,
but so was my brother Bang.
It's like,
wow,
all sorts of things that didn't make
sense anymore.
Just fall into place.
You get this articulated representation
that can sum up a whole bunch of what
would you call them?
Divergent and apparently unrelated image
representations and then all of a sudden
your path forward is clearer because you
know more about who you are and you knew
more about how you,
where you're going.
So in that is in large part what's
happening in psychoanalysis.
It's certainly what happens with dream
analysis,
which is something that Freud also
pioneered,
know Freud,
believed that dreams were wish
fulfillments and you know,
and he believed that the function of
dreams about wish fulfillments were to
protect sleep.
So for example,
maybe you're really thirsty and you go
to sleep and you dream about drinking
water.
Some of you who have consumed too much
beer the night before it might be
familiar with those sorts of dreams and
so you're dreaming that you're searching
out fountains and you're drinking and
Freud's interpretation that would be
well.
You should stay asleep.
And so the dream is providing your
underlying interrelated motivational
systems.
Say the one that governs thirst with the
fulfillment of desire.
But I think that's.
I really think that's wrong.
Although it's weird because dreams of
course could be doing all sorts of
things,
but.
But what seems to happen instead,
I realized this most particularly once I
heard about a study about the effects of
testosterone cycling testosterone on
female sexual activity.
So the plan is this,
is that in women,
testosterone levels vary across the
monthly cycle and sodas,
sexual desire,
and what seems to happen is that as
testosterone,
testosterone increases,
the frequency of sexual acts doesn't
necessarily increase,
but the frequency of sexual fantasy
increases and so the hormone is driving
the fantasies and then the fantasies
drive the behavior.
It's something like that.
And so the dream isn't fulfilling a
wish.
What it's doing is that's how the
motivational system manifests itself in
a plan for action.
It's like,
well,
you should be going to look for sources
of water if you're thirsty.
And so because of the,
you know,
your hypothalamus has to communicate
with you somehow.
It doesn't just grip your behavior and
move you around like a robot,
you know,
it has to indicate what the state,
what state is.
It does that all sorts of ways and then
start tilting you towards the solution
using your memories and your skills and
everything that would be related to
successful outcomes of that form,
that form in the past.
The other thing I should say about
creativity and,
and this is I think something very
useful for understanding people's
reactions to psychoanalysis.
I have a lot of creative people in my
clientele for for a variety of reasons
and some who aren't creative and
creativity is a trade and most people
aren't creative.
It's not common.
So,
and some people who are creative are so
creative.
It's just absolutely beyond
comprehension.
So the castle,
for example,
created 65,000
works of art three a day for 65 years.
Now that guy was created.
So anyways,
lots of people aren't creative and
they're not interested in psychoanalytic
ideas.
So they're not interested in
architectural ideas.
They're not really gripped by narrative.
So if you happen to be one marker for
creativity,
by the way,
for openness is really liking fiction.
So and women actually like fiction more
than men and because women are actually
slightly higher and part of openness
that men are.
So what else?
If you like poetry,
you know,
and it gives you an aesthetics.
Now,
aesthetic experience,
if you really get deeply involved in
music,
if you're able to produce things that
are created,
so if you have the kind of mind that
works in association.
So for example,
if I told you guys,
all right,
write down as many words as you can in
the next three minutes that begin with
the letter l,
those of you who are more creative would
come up with more words.
So there's a verbal fluency component.
I could say,
okay,
um,
how many uses can you think of for a
break?
And then I would score that.
The first would be how many uses you
came up with.
That'd be the sheer number I'd throw
away,
the stupid ones that make no sense.
And often you have to get a panel of
people to,
to make that judgment,
right.
You,
you know,
you could say,
well,
it's a thing that you could use it as a
thing.
It's like,
no x,
you don't get,
you don't get a score for that.
So then you get another score for how
uncommon your response was because
that's an originality dimension.
And naturally,
if you calculate those two dimensions,
fluency and originality from a divergent
thinking tasks,
which is the what I just told you about,
you can predict how creative people are
quite well anyways.
The really creative people seem to have
a deep wellspring of unconscious ideas
that are always flowing forth.
And some of those people dream like mad
and they have extremely sophisticated
and complex dreams and those dreams seem
to guide their behavior.
So and that's quite,
that's quite entertaining when you see
that in psychotherapy,
if you have an interest in such things
and you might say,
well,
how do you know if your dream
interpretation is true?
And that's answer that is,
well,
how do you know how you interpreted the
last book you read is true?
And the answer that is you don't know
how you don't.
And even if you did,
you don't know how you know it,
right?
Because lots of people can read a book
and they come away with slightly
different interpretations of it.
And that's because did imagine that the
book is a multilevel pattern and then
the reader is a multilevel pattern.
And then if you put those two together,
you get a multilevel pattern that's made
out of the reader end of the book,
and that's going to be unique for every
single reader except that we have
commonalities of structure and so that
we can communicate about it.
So you read a book and it strikes you,
certain things strike you in certain
things seem right.
If you do a dream interpretation,
it's a collaboration between you and the
client about the,
about the interpretation.
So usually what I do is I have people,
first of all,
they'll tell me their dream from
beginning to end.
Now Freud would say already you're
introducing all sorts of bias because
they're not telling you the dream.
They're telling you the dream as they
interpret and remember it.
It's like,
yeah,
that's a problem.
So,
but you do what you can,
you know.
And I tell people,
just write it down as fast as you can
and try not to think about too much
because we don't want post dream
editing.
So then I'll listen to it and then then
they'll tell it to me again slowly.
And then I'll listen to a sentence and
I'll let my association network work on
it and see if,
see what that reminds me of,
and then I'll ask the person what it
reminds them of and then we'll talk
about these.
Those are the direct association.
So those are the things Freud would call
free associations.
And you could say,
well around every utterance,
like a sentence,
there's a collection of potential
meanings,
right?
And those meetings might be direct
meanings,
like really tightly associated with it
to sort of loose meanings.
And so you can hit it back and forth
with the client and therapist until you
think,
oh yeah,
okay.
That seems to be.
That seems to be where that's going.
And you're also thinking about it in
relationship to the person's current
life experiences and the rest of the
dream and maybe all the dreams they told
you about before.
So it's insanely complicated,
but it's what people do when they listen
to a conversation,
you know,
how do you,
how do you know your interpretation of a
conversation is true?
Well,
you know,
there's a variety of ways that you can
approximate that.
But yet you don't know and there's lots
of different ways of interpreting a
conversation.
That's why the postmodernists,
you know,
ended up in their little hole with
regards to literature.
They realized that,
well,
there's no limit to the number of ways
you can interpret a book.
And,
but then they took the next step which
was the therefore it has no meaning.
It's like,
no,
wrong,
wrong.
It's very unsophisticated thinking.
It just means that the way the book
portrays meaning is exceedingly complex
and you can't describe it using normal
linear rationality doesn't mean the
meaning isn't there.
That's so pathetic that it's dangerous
too,
because it means that nothing has any
meaning.
And you know,
that's the most dangerous theory that.
So anyways,
you talked to the person about the dream
and the dream image and what that
triggers off in their memory.
And you also watch what they say because
sometimes.
So for example,
someone,
this just happened recently,
someone might be describing a dream
where they know where they're wandering
around somewhere and they'll say,
and I'm taking the wrong road.
You Think,
oh,
okay,
well now we know what your dream meant
because he just said it.
I'm taking the wrong road,
and that's a Freudian slip and it's so
interesting because if you listen to
people tell their dreams,
you have to kind of listen.
It's like they have two minds talking at
the same time and one is describing the
dream,
but the other one is describing their
life and they don't even notice the
connection and you pointed out and they
go,
oh yeah,
right,
right.
I didn't know I said that,
and that's a Freudian slip and I think
what's happening in part is the right
hemisphere,
which is an image accumulation and
aggregation system.
It's kind of a low resolution pattern
collection system users mostly images
and it tries to put them together in
meaningful ways,
but the meaning is vague and
comprehensive and then the left
hemisphere roughly speaking,
which is the linguistic hemisphere,
is trying to state what that says in
words and it's very difficult to make
that,
to make that transformation.
But that's why dream analysis works and
part is because you're facilitating the
movement of the information in the
images into the articulated part of the
personality here,
moving information up,
the abstraction hierarchy to the point
where it can be well utilized and that's
now I'll end this with all end,
this discussion of Freud with a
description of some research that was
done recently by relatively recently,
let's say the last 20 years by this
psychologist at the University of Texas
at Austin,
who's name is James Pennebaker and
pennebaker's,
particularly smart psychologist.
He had this idea.
Freud had another idea that was related
to therapy and he thought that what
happened if you came into therapy and
you talked about a traumatic event,
was that you were cured by Catharsis,
which meant that that trauma had to have
a bunch of emotion associated with it
and that was repressed,
but it was down there and kind of
struggling to get up and causing you all
sorts of stress and misery.
Trying to hold it down.
And then if you could just tell someone
about it and like express your feelings,
then that would help you.
Expressing your feelings does not help
you by the way,
but,
but because that,
that turns out to be wrong,
although it's wrong in an interesting
and useful way because it sort of,
it's almost right.
So what pennebaker did was he took
undergraduates and he had them come into
the lab and for three sequential days
and he had them write for 15 minutes
each day about the worst thing that they
had ever done or the worst thing that
had ever happened to them.
Often people are traumatized by
something they did,
not something that happened to them.
In fact,
more often is someone watches themselves
do something absolutely horrific.
And then they think,
oh my God,
I did that.
Who am I?
They don't know.
Then that's,
you know,
things started coming unglued.
So anyways,
pennebaker had them do that and then for
the next two weeks they felt pretty
wretched about it.
And so that's interesting because if
they would have only measured the result
of the intervention in a two week
timespan,
everyone would've said never,
never write down your traumatic
experiences because it'll make you
worse.
But over the next six months,
what happened in particular was that
their physical health improved.
They went to the doctor last year,
reported less illness and so forth,
and it's because their overall level of
stress decreased for complex reasons
that we can talk about later.
But then pennebaker,
Vegan and they excellent scientists,
he thought,
okay,
well Catharsis works here.
You're expressing your trauma and Poof,
you're fixed.
But he went back and he thought,
well wait a second,
maybe how you express it matters.
So we went back and he counted all the
words that were associated with emotion
and all the words that were associated
with understanding and cognition and
what he found was two things.
One was the more words that you use,
particularly as your narrative developed
that indicated comprehension and
understanding the better you did over
time,
and so what happens is not,
it's not the expressing of your emotion,
it's the expressing of your emotion and
then the weaving of the memory into a
new coherent representation from which
you derive a moral.
So what's the moral of a trauma?
Don't let it happen again.
That's the moral and the threat systems
are going to be throwing that thing up
at you constantly until you figure it
out.
How did I get into this?
How do I avoid it in the future?
That doesn't mean it's your fault,
but your anxiety systems,
they don't care about that.
They care about how you're not going to
fall into the same hole and the only way
to do that is to analyze the causal
pathways that lead to the whole to begin
with and see if you can either
reconfigure your behavior and your
attitudes so that that doesn't happen
again,
or maybe you just don't go those places
anymore.
You know either way and you're the
trauma threat systems.
As soon as you come up with a
comprehensive representation that you
believe in,
they'll leave you alone,
and this can happen very,
very rapidly with nightmares.
I've,
I've cured people's nightmares in one
session,
no problem.
I asked them to bring their nightwear to
opt in to their imagination.
Maybe someone's chasing them.
It's like,
okay,
think about them chasing.
You got to visualize it.
Really visualize it.
The more real you make it,
the better.
Okay.
They're being chased.
How are you feeling?
I'm all anxious and afraid.
Okay,
turn around and look at the thing that's
chasing you.
So they do that.
Then maybe they tell,
say what it is or whatever,
but maybe they don't even do that and I
say,
okay,
now before you go to bed at night,
just when you're almost falling asleep,
you're in a hypnagogic state where
images are starting to come.
You run that,
they run that Poof,
that nightmare is gone and the reason
for it is that they've now reconfigured
themselves as the thing,
not the thing that's being chased.
That's prey animal.
They've configured themselves as the
thing that can turn around and face the
thing that's chasing them and that's the
same Motif as the dragon haunting the
union archetypes,
right face what you're afraid of it not
will cure you,
and that's really one of the fundamental
motifs of Freud and psychoanalysis.
So you know you have an exam on
Thursday.
I'll post questions about sort of
representative questions on the exam
when I get home after this lecture,
probably this evening,
the latter there.
The essays are,
the test is here.
It's multiple choice.
You'll have no problem finishing it.
It's not that loan,
and if you've done the readings and come
to the lectures,
you'll probably do fine.
So it's not a tricky test.